so wait a minute you work at the wuhan
respiratory coronavirus lab
the disease is the same name as the lab
he is not wrong he is not wrong all
right
oh my god oh my god so last night
something kind of magical happened on
cbs
yeah i know stephen colbert's show is
terrible and and really he's just
bad at this whole comedy thing he used
to be good when he was on comedy central
and he was playing bill o'reilly then he
lost his main character
and basically since then he's been in
competition with
jimmy kimmel for the title of pope of
wokedom
one is the pope and one as the anti-pope
but in any case he's not been good at
his job for a while because he's too
busy bootlicking the democrats well john
stewart
who was the predecessor to trevor noah
and jon stewart you have to say
yeah i disagreed with him a lot of the
time i thought he was wrong on about 85
of issues but actually was a talented
guy jon stewart guested
on stephen colbert and he proceeded to
spend like eight minutes delving into
the lab league theory with regard to
coronavirus
and dude is spot on and you can see
stephen colbert is super annoyed
and also very confused and he can't
believe that jon stewart
is lending credibility to this evil
trumpian talking point here is jon
stewart going off
i think we owe a great debt of gratitude
to science science has in many ways
helped
ease uh the suffering of this
pandemic which was
more than likely caused by science
okay and you can see that colbert is
kind of annoyed by this at one point he
asks jon stewart do you work for ron
johnson now
because it's become such a ridiculous
talking point on the left
that the wuhan lab leak theory had to be
some sort of crazy trumpian conspiracy
theory
that here is jon stewart laying out some
fairly
basic logic and cobain just can't handle
it
oh my god there's evidence i'd love to
hear there's a novel
respiratory coronavirus overtaking wuhan
china
what do we do oh you know who we could
ask the
wuhan novel respiratory coronavirus lab
the disease is the same name as the lab
that's just that's just a little too
weird don't you think and then they ask
those scientists they're like
how did this so wait a minute you work
at the wuhan
respiratory coronavirus lab how did this
happen and they're like
a pangolin kissed a turtle
he is not wrong he is not wrong it turns
out there has yet to be a bat in the
wild identified with covet 19
you may have noticed and he didn't stop
there he might like this for like eight
minutes more john stewart listen to this
wait a second
all right josh oh my god oh my god
there's been an outbreak of chocolatey
goodness
near hershey pennsylvania what do you
think happened
like oh i don't know maybe a steam
shovel made it with a cocoa bean or it's
the
chocolate factory maybe that's it
yep now that fairly compelling logic
has been used by you know everybody
who's proponents of the wuhan lab league
theory for a year
if you're john stewart it's fine if you
were somebody on facebook who said it or
if you were senator tom cotton who said
it then you're very very
bad you're very bad so will jon stewart
be kicked out
of the social graces hall for the
democratic party of course not
of course not but it does make for some
rather uncomfortable moments and
and frankly the humor here is not just
jon stewart saying things that are
pretty obviously true it is also the
utter level of sheer discomfort
experienced by both the audience and
stephen colbert
in the middle of this rant it really is
amazing
says mediaite colbert acknowledged that
health officials say the matter requires
more investigation though he and stewart
went back and forth over the theory's
merits
colbert said how long have you worked
for senator ron johnson
and stewart said this isn't a conspiracy
this is the problem with science
science is incredible but they don't
know when to stop okay again the fact
that colbert had to
look for a reason to slap back here as
opposed to just
laughing just demonstrates that once
again
colbert so much of the late night crew
they're run by the democratic party
yeah it's it's amazing these people are
so bad at this
the folks on the left and in the media
they're so bad at this that they're
going to usher republicans back into
power
and they might assure trump back into
power because of all of this if they
make it
the hill that they die on that china is
wonderful and definitely didn't create
this lab league if the hill that they
die on
is that donald trump was terrible on
china but we have to be really
conciliatory toward china
man go for it really enjoy stephen
colbert
truly did you know that every single
like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science
[Music]